welcome to this video playing endless
fighter from from India this guy
I think yet another fly at one point
didn't have the Bangladesh like or
something okay
we have a decision by the way we have a
Sicilian the closest so you know when I
played the nor the a6 this is just to to
get some yeah to get some variety in the
position the closest silly in a very
often is played with g6 which is of
course perfectly alright but some
variety is not a bad thing and a6 is
quite decent against the closed a6 and
b5 it's it's a tad slow but it's it's
playable hmm yeah this is a very very
direct way to play
well yeah
yeah maybe this is really good-looking
moose is just winning this pawn I mean
it looks really unnatural but maybe it's
it's mocking possible with rook a 7 I'm
trying to trying to protecting this
bishop so this is this is a pinion
Knight f6 is not a threat here looky
what is a threat though and a really big
one yeah yeah castles is also not really
great there maybe I need to do it so
yeah come on let's let's do that if he
takes at least she loses even more time
with the Queen and we have two bishops
trade it yeah I don't I don't hear you
can one can win c5 don't mind takes B
sub I can't take with Luke actually
no Queen trade I mean this is what I
didn't want Jim not just a pawn down
maybe you can even play Queen d6 just
attacking c5 Hobart couldn't be seven
okay I've got Queen b7 just important in
any case even after move yeah can the
screen d6 it's not it's not not great
but you can they can do that
maybe I'm not really threatening
anything yeah it just takes it it's
possible that I'm not really threatening
anything I can give a check but I just
have three and and that's it
nothing nothing much you can do at least
I gained against some time okay let's go
here intending night be 495 I mean what
is what should probably have it all most
decisive advantage but I can always
always be a be a bit annoying in this
position trying to confuse them I will
see to singing but I will take it I mean
no doubt about that I will take the spot
95 also as possible I hope you probably
Queenie form
yeah that's not good you need to do that
check so let's let's see is this how bad
is this I mean I regained the pawn but
it's it's still quite quite ugly my back
rank is especially weak I mean if I
would have had h6 played in this
position or g6 this wouldn't be so
terrible I mean worse of thusly but but
not not lost can I do that it's very
ambitious yep probably need to I can
take it
sorry now I can just take it and this
was the Jataka and I simply forgot about
this check
so Jenkins he gets into winning
component game yeah I could I could
resign but let's let's just play it out
let him I mean he will he will manage
but it's so nice to see for for some us
I guess how to how to win this position
it's really not much that I can do here
yeah this is useful I mean
checked he has this is H bone and yeah
this is where you can just move any part
now and then he would enter so I mean I
probably didn't even play the most
tenacious defense but it's lost anyway
yeah this was bad black resigns yeah
somewhat strange somewhere strange game
queenie of three years really sync
signals but if it works it works
computers as whites is winning with this
one but exactly the stuff from Queen f3
even before the comp line now is King f8
which is really strange
okay I understand king of Aida what a
mean firm no you miss playing like that
but it's a it's interesting the ideas
after takes I have g5 and then he
doesn't have a check so yeah well King
f8 is so ugly I didn't consider it so
Brooke a7 takes takes check you know
this is just you have 26 I mean I saw it
right after 96 and here it's ugly but I
think I really didn't it isn't this some
play at least serene Bishop d2 Esther
come move Knight c2 looks you won
check yeah of course I mean Rock t6 was
a joke a complete joke yeah but if I
have no move it seven hangs so funny
that there's also the computer move I
mean which loses completely I mean okay
this is just just this sucks
it's not it's not a key and porn end
game which is completely dead
here you can at least have some slight
hopes and that he blundered upon back or
something but of course white is
completely winning this means that this
g5 move is not good
okay okay okay here I need to play
before this is actually a good idea as
this wins lots of time and after here I
can I can even play Bishop g5
interesting huh so this is the real
point this is just just bad then with
the weakness is not defendable
interesting so learn something about
this this offbeat opening line alright
thanks for watching